okay good afternoon
first of all I would like everyone to
close your eyes and imagine you are in a
factory and you are going to pick I
phone covers from a bin to become mayor
or you can do some quality inspection or
the both apart for scratches or dents
that's not easy if you can see okay open
yours again if you were a robot you
might be pre-programmed that's not easy
take some time and it kind of static but
so if you were a robot and have eyes I
can see like human and even you can see
in the dark or in the bright environment
or if you can see all kinds of
components
wouldn't that be okay
[Music]
my name is Arielle Franken from a
company called civet it's a small
start-up and what we make is this type
of product it's the 3d camera for
robotics so providing the eyes of the
robot so during this session I would
like to speak about the product and I
would like to to to give you some
information about why we are making this
product I can talk about I will talk
about technology and what's under the
hood after the camera and I will also
talk about give you a brief description
of the history of the company and talk
about little bit about culture and what
drives great innovation and I will wrap
up with that having a deer move in them
so real I real demo so let's talk about
the why we made this product when I talk
about industrial revolutions you have
first we had the steam machine and then
you have electricity and the beginning
of mass production with Henry Ford we
had the invention of computer in the 60s
and the beginning of automation but what
we have now is what we call the fourth
Industrial Revolution that's where you
know a computer and automation comes
together in an entirely new way so you
have machines devices sensors and people
that are communicated and the decisions
are often distributed down to the
devices around in the factory floor or
in the warehouses and that's our
playground
and talking about robotics robots has
been existing for many years as I said
but in the past those robot has been me
they have been expensive and not so
flexible and difficult to use and often
there are you know big companies like
automotive companies and such that can
afford those robots and do add
automation but the shift we see now in
the market it's towards what we call
collaborative robots so those are
smaller and more flexible so they can be
moved around in the factory floor much
easier they are much easier to use and
then they can work together with with
people so we think the key enabler to
make this happen is 3d robot vision
because these robots they need the ice
and they need brains so in terms of our
product and the competition out there we
have in a one end of the scale you have
what's coming from the consumer you know
you know the Kinect camera realsense
from Intel those camera they are bit
fast but they also have low cost but
they have low accuracy so we are talking
about maybe in the millimeters and on
the other end of the scale you have high
accuracy laser scanners typically they
are more expensive and very slow so what
we have tried to do with this product is
to try to combine you want to make it
accurate and fast at the same time
that's kind of the uniqueness of the
product in addition we also are handling
colors were able to detect color
different colors
inside their product we have some
filters so for example if you are should
pick shiny objects you might have
reflections so we have a filter that is
removing reflections for example you can
see there that you have one with without
a reflexion filter and then with a
reflexion filter on you also have you
know HDR I guess most of you have heard
about that in the camera right high
dynamic range to increase the dynamic
dynamic dynamic range of the image so
you are able to capture both bright and
dark objects so we have done that in in
3d yeah so our product it's a metal
housing it's robust it also can handle
its water and dust resistant and also it
can be either mounted onto a robot arm
or it can be a kind of at the head of
the robot or it could be mounted the
stationary if you like it if you like to
pick something from a bin you can place
it over the bin so some example of
applications been picking the robot with
the camera can do a simple kitting
assembly it can measure different kind
of objects you know dimensional
measurements it can it can inspect if
you have you know some sometimes you
have people looking at parts you to see
if there are scratches and dents right
production errors it can detect that you
can see the difference between and pick
different red apples and green apples
and in the logistics you can think about
you can pick
back products coming from the storehouse
so many different application it can be
used for
[Music]
yeah so now you understand why we made
this product and what it's used for and
they kept ability so now I would like to
give you some more insight what's inside
the product and there are different
kinds of 3d technology you can have what
we call time-of-flight those are
typically consumer and actually in the
iPhone 10 you have time-of-flight
3d camera that's actually when you are
sending IR and measure the time and the
face when it's reflected back to the
camera and that's as it's high-speed but
it's not so great for higher accuracy
but then you also have a stereo vision
when you are using two cameras and you
can have a Laser laser scanner so
different kind of technologies so what
we have used is what we call struck to
light so that's why we have inside our
camera we have actually a projector or
what we call our optical engine and we
have a 2d camera which is of axis
towards the engine so the engine is
projecting several multiple types of
patterns and the cat the camera and the
engine they are calibrated towards flat
surface so when patterns are distorted
the camera can see how much is the
distortion and based on them that you
can calculate the depth okay em in
seaweed we have some design principles
which we are following
first of all called T and robustness
because you know high grade of
reliability and stability manufacturing
is very important because you know to
reduce the downtime if a production line
is going down it's it's very caustic
right performance so our ambition is to
not to be leading
or technology and to be have the best
performance so what we try to do is to
have the accuracy and the speed on the
color and that combination is very
unique
we have flexibility not that the
products should do everything but trying
to have a platform and features that is
able to covering different types of
applications and simplicity is very
important to us because our customers
they are typically integrators so they
they buy the camera they buy a robot the
by an analytic software package and they
are developing a system Arab boots L
that is not so that's a complex thing to
do and we are trying to to put effort to
make this more simple for for the user
so to reduce the time it takes to to
develop a robot cell but also to if you
think about you should do different
things with its robot cell you know to
me to make it simpler and easier to
reconfigure and we deploy when we did
the industrial design of this product
that was an interesting journey and what
we try to do them is to humanize the
technology bit you can you can probably
see that you know it reminds you
probably of some of the robotic
characters that out there so we have you
know the projector on the camera it's
kind of the eyes and you have the
heatsink
as they're kind of the hair on the side
blowing in the wind you know you might
have see the moles on the beard so
trying to humanize that but the main
thing about industrial design is that
you need to think you need to design it
from inside out and outside in at the
same time you can't do the the
industrial design and then figure out
what parts that is going into the
product that's important that's the key
learning
so if you look at under the hood you can
see there's a camera and the projector
and there's a lot of optics in the in
the camera so we are putting a lot of
effort into optimizing the optics and
also now we are doing our own design
because we see this as the critical
components for story to have the really
good performance of the product and
stable the control board is so first of
all we are we are using the PC so what
we are doing with the camera is
providing information of the 3d
coordinates so XY set color and contrast
sending that to the to the PC and GPU on
the PC is it's computing the point cloud
the 3d model so that we have under
control board we have a microcontroller
and we have also on our latest version
is we put a lot quite a lot of sensors
because they don't cost anything right
so we put in accelerometers we put in
humidity sensor temperature pressure and
that's for you don't think we don't know
everything we are going to use it for
but you know that open up opportunities
for for new features and you can think
about diagnostic for example will be
important when it's in the market to try
to understand what the products are used
for you know the temperature the
pressure the rotation it's interesting
information which might we use
calculator yep
currently we are doing the projector so
but for this this was kind of a semi
custom engine I will say so it's kind of
based on a pico projector that we did
some modification to it so what we are
doing now is more custom going for yes
to have more stability and to have
better optical performance related to
temperature for example another key
finding is also you know to invest in
test equipment because we don't have the
time you know to be in a queue at the
third party test outs so we are we are
thinking short iterations and you need
to test and get feedback on what you are
building so we are trying to invest in
test equipment in house you know too
short a time to market but also to
improve quality so it also software in
save it we have a small young and
international team I will say our main
language are C++ we do have a Nigel
workflow with daily meetings we have
tried to keep the repository clean and
doing future branches we are doing pull
request and code reviews so it's kind of
a high degree of automation and we try
to document in the code you know
typically agile way of working so using
modern C++ so what we are delivering C++
11 but we also you know internally we
are you know using features and looking
at C++ 17 so it's not the black and
white thing but you know not doing to
include all the customers we are using
C++ 11
it's a cross-platform so it compiles on
both linux and windows
and we also GPU we have put a lot of
effort into GPU programming because you
know the capture time is important but
also the processing time right for on
the GPU so it's the the whole chain
which is important so optimizing that
the GPU is is something that v that we
do trying to have a simplicity as the
core value so we are providing api's you
know for our customers so they can they
can program in Titan net - Jenny cam so
we are making kind of having this the
the C++ as the core the providing api's
in different languages trying to find
the right balance between reusing and
the core but and doing wrappers so
developers are familiar with with the
different languages and only a few line
you know lines to require is required to
capture your first first first image
yeah
so it takes continuous integration
series that's for best quality and speed
and using Jenkins pipelines with the
various type of Dockers and VirtualBox
images for Linux I mean the windows it
it's built and tested on Ubuntu Linux
and windows different kinds of compilers
like clang Jesus Ian MCC and we also use
different kinds of modern tools to have
a broad test correction
so you know the first year or two was
kind of make sure we fix the stability
the quality the compatibility that's
kind of building the foundation on the
platform for for future use that has
been our focus now they are trying to to
broaden up and and focus more on machine
nation to to make things simpler for the
user but also to to improve the
performance so we are you know working
on a ps4 with different kinds of tool
sets for the user in a machine machine
and also looking into AI you know to use
this at the technology to to do improve
the performance for example the speed
and to handle different objects we don't
have a CAD model to compared with
different different things in that ok so
that's was little but little about
technology so I would like to go through
a little bit a history of the company so
save it is a it's a young company it was
founded by these two guys Henry
criminals now my stands go time they
were symptom researchers and they've
been working together for 15 years
incentive which is the largest resource
institution in Scandinavia so they
actually didn't be working with machine
mission and automation and robotics for
for a long time right that they they
were soft people and developed
algorithms but I saw that they were not
a really good sensor in the market that
were both accurate and high speed so
that's why they made a prototype with
some help of some from consultants they
use their the rest of their project
moment to to have a spam
in Mission in Stuttgart to test this
product and there
the feedback was fantastic so they they
got a lot of good response so they done
when they decided no we need to go back
and establish a company so that was the
start so the company was was established
three years ago yeah here's a we are in
the prototype phase some more people are
coming to the team and you might wonder
why we put product in the fridge so the
thing that we actually discovered when
we had the first prototype and started
to test it was that you know that its
its optical engine and LED as they are
generating hits of course and things
were actually not stable it was
expanding right and that's not a good
for a camera that should have an
accuracy of 0.1 millimeter so we were
looking at the calibration and figure
out we have to calibrate for different
temperatures so we had to cool down the
unit to 10 degrees and up to 50 and
heated up the board to 5050 and use
different kind of calibration for for
every temperatures so but that we were
able to solve that problem so it's a
good and also to optimize the the
cooling system from a hardware
perspective so it's a good example of
software and hardware coming together to
solve the problem
we were very creative I try to cool down
the unit we bought ice cubes from the
grocery stores
that's not still something we can do in
production but it worked for a prototype
but a lot of creative ideas you know to
solve these problems here you can see
with the vibration testing you know the
easy way and a bit more sophisticated
way
and it should resist water so we were
having some creative medals to test it
for water ingression so why don't for
the water inside the unit so to see if
it doesn't come out the water so that
was things we did but it you know we we
finally tested it at a test house so it
was more according to the standard but
that was you know when you're a startup
you need to figure out things like that
right and calibration is important part
is it was thoroughly in the early we did
a very simple calibration with a plane
at the bottom there but no we have more
sophisticated calibration system where
we have a ventilation control and also a
correcting for so temperature but also
for optical errors so for example we
have an industry cooler that we need to
build a room for so it's more more
sophisticated than more expensive but it
works so a lot of challenges when you're
a start-up right on making a new product
so another challenge we had was to get
attention from our suppliers or partners
so for example we were using this engine
and talking to these guys in in Asia
they are building maybe half a million a
million projector or engine sprayer and
then we come a small company five people
we like to buy a hundred this year and
by the way we need to do some
modifications that's not easy so so
that's why we need it needed to go to
Asia yeah I think we have been there
maybe seven or eight times over the last
couple of years need to be in the
relationship and what you need to sell
is not the hub that we're going to buy
home rabbit need to sell the potential
in the market you need to you know to
you know think iRobot ice to the ice to
the robot so so by doing that we get
more attention
but it's about the relationship and need
to be the face face to face and also to
go through you know problems that we
need to solve together you can't do that
on email you need to be there and go
through it with them on the whiteboard
that's that's fairly important here's
another example of challenge we had this
is the profile there will the end closer
so it's it's made by technical execution
so it's kind of an aluminium block which
is heated and it pushed the tool and
then it comes out a long profile but the
problem that we had was when it was cool
down one side was kind of bending more
than the other because we have more
material material on one side so we
ended up by adding more material to the
whole enclosure anchoring it off after
it's expensive but it works and it's
yeah so a lot of challenges there as
well yeah this was a proud moment we
shipped the first unit and built and
shipped by employee number three and
four and the guy who built the first
products in the lab went to the partner
that should produce the product I'm kind
of acting as the production manager
another thing when you're a start-up we
need to do all kinds of things so during
these trips to Asia we used the
opportunity to talk to talk to potential
customers as well selling so put on the
the suit and selling the product as well
and we met these guys as well they were
selling this cloud chamber which we
ended up buying and two one fourth of
the price compared to the Whitsun price
so
we were located in this in start-up lab
which is attacking she beta rating Oslo
it was really good
okay sorry incubator where where you
have 60 and 70 people 78 companies
struggling with the same things it's
really good you know to be there and you
know discuss and talk about the same
problems fear we have I really good yeah
we had hot dogs on me every Friday we
were out in the field a lot out in the
field on exhibitions here you can see
Henrik is doing some creative selling we
may actually made the trolley so we were
rolling this relay around an exhibition
floor try to attract people because you
have this blinking right so it's easy to
attract people so I was creative selling
and this was us so we expanded to us
early this year and started to sell
there and we attended the vision show
and I got this price which for the best
3d camera and of course we have a lot of
thumb so you know we are a small family
and you know going to hamsa doll or you
know you know things like that is very
important for a startup people to get
this good feeling alright so we have a
we have a product award-winning product
so what what I'm going to into now is
you know to give you some my take on
what what drives great innovation and
that's not based not only on the the two
years I've been working at save it but
also on I used to work at Cisco LED
development there and whether you are a
small start-up or a bigger corporate
company there are a few things that are
important so first of all you need to
have the right people number one you
need to have the right people with the
right skills the passion and the
engagement that's the most important
people that could drive you know the
engagement and and really do the
improvements the second is the is the
purpose so all you can think people
could be the DNA of the company the
purpose should be the religion because
you need to have the the direction you
need to have the strategy and you need
to have the purpose why are you making
this and you need to understand you know
what type of problems you will solve for
the customers so with the people on the
purpose and the third thing is the
culture so culture is important but it's
about how you're working together you
know how are you solving the problems
together so that's so now I'm going to
talk a little bit about it lasting the
culture and you probably seen this
before so if you have I guess Conway's
law basically it says how you organize
your team and how you how the
communication is going between the teams
and people will shape your product and I
think that's not only for software but
it's for hardware as well you need to
find you know the right communication
structure that's that's because it will
reflect on your product you know how it
will be so I think you know focusing on
and follow Conway's law organized into
product and feature teams to have this
close interaction between disciplines
you know self-directing quick decisions
and so on and you need to keep the focus
need to understand
and solve the real consumer problems and
think user experience them the second is
to think a gel not only in software but
in hardware as well need to have this
progressive development which short
iteration you know be the show in your
development you know use demos I use min
boards and image in videos and this is
to get feedback right you do you know to
build and have short iteration and to
get feedback on what you build and that
can be testing for internal in it to get
feedback from internal people it could
be testing with you know temperature or
whatever and it could be testing and
checking out at the customer need to our
goals because if you don't any need to
track them because if you don't know
where you're going you will never get
there so to have goals from bottom-up
and top-down and which is all our line
with strategy and direction need to be
measured and it's it's you know cool to
take some risk you know to have some
high potential goals and need to have
regular check-ins and to understand
where everybody are the last thing is
about empowerment and I think that it's
coming with the ownership you have need
to have ownership of what you are
working on and to be involved early on
and value diverse and I think
empowerment is nothing something you get
is something you take
so here it's about you know they're
having the right people again you know
the right passion so so where do I see
the future of David okay so we have we
have a good sensor a 3d camera we will
go into machine vision and adding more
features to your product taking more
ownership of the brain
but most importantly I think to build a
great team is the most important you
know to be to build a great culture a
great learning culture it's the way we
are going to succeed because every every
everything else can be copied but
culture cannot be copied thank you
[Applause]
so let's see to end the presentation
it's here and let's see if I if I close
this maybe it helps
mmm yeah I tried it before so should be
so so up here stretch so do you like
like ystem okay yeah
so let's see we can do capture okay I
have it here now yeah so this is my 2 K
capture and I took a hundred millisecond
to capture it so what you see the
resolution on this projector is not good
so you can't really see the high
accuracy but you get get the sense what
what you can do you see ever these dots
have a 3d information and you can rotate
we can do live know it generate 3d point
cloud or a second 10 10 3d clouds I can
turn off the color so you can see that
the it's better to see that what you get
and when you get data when you turn off
the color and you can let's see let's
try HDR I have a white and black objects
there so if I do just you can't really
see the black one right there's no data
there but if you do
HDR come
different images you can maybe see you
can't see it here you can see it there
on the projector but let's see you try
to yeah we can see it a little bitter
it's not easy to see well let's see I'm
the crease shooting this as well
okay AB yeah is easier to see that but
I'm blaming the projectors so this is
sir this is when you do HDR yeah only
how things like yeah you know as I said
the reflexion filter which is actually
all you shouldn't be but we have that so
that's more for shiny objects and see
let's see maybe one can I have a bullet
or okay you okay cold you want to have
do a selfie the cool they cool itself
ever so if you can be there a little bit
you can see on the cup see you look in
the camera layer
yeah
so basically with 0.1 millimeter you can
actually see the difference between here
and here is about 0.1 millimeter it's
not easy to see on this projector but
you get that yeah okay
thank you any questions I think we have
five minutes yep
we haven't actually got any negative
feedback I bet because in most cases
this blinking happens not regularly it's
maybe a blink if you if you have a robot
that is going to pick something on from
a bin maybe if you have a blink every
five seconds or so so it's not if we
haven't seen that as a big problem but
it is possible to use IR as well as well
yeah it is yeah the camera is 2.3
megapixels so every every pixel has the
equipment the XY set 3d information
what are you referring to yeah
so we're providing the api's and this is
just less decay just for demo and such
but we are api's so what we are actually
providing is the point cloud the 3d
model so you have you need to have some
analytic software on top of it to
actually figure out what to use it for
and tell the robot what to do and that's
what we are also looking into so we
trying to in the future do some more
features analytic tools that we can by
this analytic tools from third-party
software houses yeah ambient light and
reflections are difficult conditions but
we have we have filters that are
removing reflections so we are actually
pretty good hambling shiny objects so
car industry for example they are using
a lot so yeah we have you have
algorithms that are handling it now
there are those are digital filters yes
it's also related to how you are
projecting the patterns so we have
different patterns for example you have
patterns oriented different ways and in
addition there are also other magic
stuff inertia which I don't know all
about
anymore okay thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]